[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
27 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Hey, Francesc.
How are you doing?
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Pretty good.
Pretty good.
Enjoying GOTO in Chicago.
MARK MANDEL: Ooh, fancy.
How's that going?
FRANSESC CAMPOY: It's
surprisingly hot.
But the conference is amazing.
Very good talks.
I just came out from a talk by
Sam Newman on microservices.
He basically had a
slide saying that Go is
the best language you can use.
So I'm pretty happy.
MARK MANDEL: That would
make you happy, yes.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Yep.
So today we're going to
be talking about something
slightly related
to microservices.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
we're going to have
an interesting conversation
with John Feminella.
There we go.
That's fun.
We're going to talk
about unikernels.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Yep.
So basically what
are unikernels?
Why could you even
care about them?
How do you use them?
What are the current
solutions, technical solutions,
that are available
already to run unikernels?
And also how to run them
on Google Cloud Platform.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so that's
a pretty cool and interesting
thing.
And then, towards
the end, it's back
to my little pet project,
Deployment Manager.
We have a really interesting
question around that as well.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I like
it because it's basically
how to do Deployment Manager
without doing Deployment
Manager, which is perfect.
I really like it.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Well, before we get
into those two things,
why don't we have a quick
chat about the cool thing
of the week?
We've got a few things, given
that Google I/O was last week.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, there were
a lot of very interesting
announcements at Google I/O.
But out of all the ones
related to Google Cloud,
by far my favorite one is
the new version of Firebase.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
this is pretty awesome.
We've gone from having a few
really interesting services
with Firebase to having lots
of really interesting services
with Firebase.
It's pretty amazing.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, and you still
keep on having that free tier
after 100 concurrent users,
which is actually more
than any of my [INAUDIBLE]
have ever got.
So I'm very, very,
very happy with that.
But on top of that, I don't
have the list in front of me,
but there was analytics,
there was storage, what else?
MARK MANDEL: So
there's analytics.
There's storage-- integration
with Google Cloud Storage,
it's just a really nice
veneer over the top.
We've got remote config
for doing experiments,
being able to do, like,
sort of key value pairs.
What other stuff
have we got in there?
There's so many good things.
There's even, like,
little things,
like handy little tweaks
to how you can update data
within the realtime database.
All sorts of good stuff.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Nice.
So yeah, we'll have a
link on the show notes
to documentation of
the new Firebase.
So you can check it out.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
And we'll have links
to all the Firebase
sessions that are available
currently from I/O. There's
a whole bunch.
And most of them
will be up currently,
although I know there's
still a few coming in as
late stragglers.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Actually,
not only the ones
related to Firebase, but all
the Google Cloud Platform
talks that were
there at Google I/O.
Because I know that you
spoke about Firebase,
but I spoke about
something else.
I spoke about Google
Cloud Spin, and we'll also
have a link to that talk.
MARK MANDEL: Yep, yep, yep.
Yeah, mine's a
little delayed, due
to some minor technical
issues, but hopefully it
should be up there fairly soon.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Wow.
And also something
that I really enjoyed
was if anyone have the
chance to go to Google I/O,
they might have seen that there
was some really cool demos
in the Cloud tent.
There was the same two
demos that we had GCP Next.
So [INAUDIBLE] and
the GCP Emotobooth,
which are both really, really
cool, developed by Instrument.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so if
you're interested in seeing
some applications of
BigQuery, or possibly
some applications
of Cloud Vision API,
you can dig into
that code and see
what it is that they did
to make the magic happen.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Yeah, so we
had those demos at GCP Next,
during Google I/O, and now
those demos are open-sourced.
All the code, you
can that on GitHub.
So github.com/instrument.
But we'll have the two links
to the repos on the show list
here.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
So if you want to
build Emotobooth
in your house for,
like, your next party,
you can totally do that now.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: That is
actually totally a good idea.
MARK MANDEL: You totally
thought about it, didn't you?
FRANSESC CAMPOY: I'm
seriously considering
doing that for my next party.
Cool.
So I think it's time to go
talk with our friend, John
Feminella, about unikernels.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, let's
go talk about unikernels.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: So I'm
very happy to welcome
John Feminella to the Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
Hey, John, how are doing?
JOHN FEMINELLA: Pretty good.
How about you guys?
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Doing great.
MARK MANDEL: Pretty well.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: So
yeah, I'm actually
very excited to have
you here, because I
saw your talk at Container
Camp a couple weeks ago
on unikernels.
And I thought it was a very
good introduction to unikernels,
explaining why and how,
and all of those things.
So I decided that it was a very
good idea to have you here.
But before we start talking
about unikernels, why don't you
tell us a little
bit about yourself?
JOHN FEMINELLA: Sure.
So you already know my name.
I'm John Feminella.
Most of what I do on
a day to day basis
is to work with a wonderful
company called Pivotal.
And most of what
I do at Pivotal is
to work with a product called
Pivotal Cloud Foundry, where
I serve as sort of a technical
advisor for companies that
are interested in taking a
look at how they modernize
the way they do enterprise
software development.
So you know, there's a lot of
really big banks and hospitals,
and other major institutions,
large and small,
that have an idea of
how they build software,
but maybe that idea
hasn't necessarily
kept pace with the
best practices of how
you deploy software in a
modern cloud-based environment.
So we try to help them with
that with Pivotal Cloud Foundry.
And my job is to kind of go
from this idealized version
of the way that
software gets built
and help them apply that
to their own enterprises,
and make them better and
more efficient at developing
software and delivering it.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Cool.
And how did you get
involved with unikernels?
Could you tell us a
little bit about the story
of how you doing these
kind of cloud software
ends up doing a talk about
unikernels at Container Camp?
JOHN FEMINELLA: Sure.
You'll often see me
giving talks about things
that I have basically
no affiliation with,
but I find incredibly
interesting in some way.
And unikernels is one
of the topics that's
very squarely in that category.
So I certainly haven't
done any academic research
in the unikernel space,
which is a lot of where
the genesis of
where we're seeing
the interest in
unikernels come from.
It was very much an
academic idea to start with,
that kind of got
gradually evolved
into an industry exploration
that's now going on.
So there haven't been
many practical examples
of unikernels until, I would
say, relatively recently
in computing history.
And that sort of is what drew
my attention to it first,
was the academic
side of the thing.
In January 2014, there
was a publication
made in a magazine called
"Communications of the ACM,"
and "CACM" is sort
of a-- it's halfway
between a formal journal
and, like, a gossip
magazine for
computer scientists.
I hope there are no "CACM"
board members on here,
because they would be very
mad at that description.
But it's basically a
very-- it's kind of a way
to get really interesting
ideas out in front
of a large audience without
necessarily requiring
the rigor of a
formal academic paper
that you might submit
to a larger journal.
And I love "CACM"
for that reason,
because it's a great
bridge from academia,
to kind of describe what they're
working on, and for industry
folks to kind of hear about
what's happening, and up
and coming.
And so there was
a paper published
in January 2014
called "Unikernels:
The Rise of the Virtual
Library Operating System,"
written by-- David J. Scott
is one of the authors,
and I'm probably going
to mispronounce his name,
but I think the other
author is Anil Madhavapeddy.
And both of them were
talking about how
this new way of consolidating
machine images and computing
resources into sort of
this discrete single thing,
in a very specific tailored way,
could yield enormous benefits.
And that was very
interesting to me,
because that's almost
the same claim that
was made for the
advantages for containers.
And when containers were
announced-- or not announced--
but when containers
were being developed
over the last decade,
or couple of decades,
as a technology, that
was one of the claims
that the proponents of
containers often pointed to,
was, like, there's
these sort of advantages
to consolidating and
minimizing the surface
area of what you're actually
delivering to a production
system.
And unikernels seems
to be something
of an extension of that idea,
at least on the surface.
And that's very
interesting to me,
because, as someone who works
a lot with cloud computing,
and working with
these enterprises
who deliver software
in the cloud,
I'm very interested
in what the correct,
or what the interesting new,
ways of deploying software
in large scale environments,
in a reliable, consistent, and
repeatable way,
what that looks like
through different strategies.
And unikernels
definitely represents
a new point in the
spectrum that I don't think
has really existed before.
So it's a new sort of
tool in our toolbox
that's evolving over time.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So before we start talking about
the advantages or disadvantages
of unikernels, why
don't you tell us
a little bit about what is
a unikernel specifically,
from the point of
view of someone
that, like me, knows Docker,
but that's pretty much it?
JOHN FEMINELLA: Sure.
So if you know about
Docker, you probably
know that the way that Docker
is able to deliver some
of the isolation
advantages that it has
is because there are specific
hooks inside of your kernel
that allow a machine that's
running Docker to guarantee
those isolation properties.
So your kernel is, in
some sense, aware of this,
and it's providing
those benefits for you.
In older, more traditional
style isolation
through virtual machines, the
way that you get isolation
is by running an
entire new OS stack
on top of your existing
OS and existing services
and libraries.
So you're basically repeating
all the work of building an OS.
And with something like Docker,
or another containerization
technology, you're
removing the need
to have kind of a big
heavy kernel in there,
and you kind of just
have lightweight hooks
into a real running
kernel, and then
you get performance
advantages by not
having to virtualize
those calls across
as many layers as a
virtual machine has to.
And unikernels go
one step farther.
And unikernels are
based on the observation
that, if you have
a kernel and you
have an OS in the form
of additional services
and libraries on top
of the kernel that
are made available to
applications-- if you have
that-- you pretty quickly reach
the conclusion that, well,
not every application
running on top of that stack
needs everything
that's in the whole OS,
and in the whole kernel.
Right?
So your web browser probably
needs a lot of the kernel,
but it probably
doesn't necessarily
need things like access to
your serial port, or whatever.
And that's true for
many different kinds
of applications.
They don't need access
to the entire kernel.
So unikernels are a
way of saying, well,
what if we didn't need to
have the whole kernel around,
and the whole OS around,
for an application?
What if we could just
take the pieces that
are relevant to an application?
And what if we could
run it that way?
What if we could
sort of only expose,
or make available, to
the application the parts
that it really depends on?
And if we can do
that, then maybe we
can ship that entire
dependency stack
as a single, consolidated
machine image.
And then, just like we can run
Docker containers containing
images, we should be able
to run sort of a container
around this consolidated
machine image.
But because that image is
effectively an entire operating
system in a bottle,
you could run that
on bare metal, or on a
hypervisor, or whatever.
And also, because
it's so much smaller,
we expect to see
certain benefits around.
Like, maybe it's quicker
to start those things up
than it would be to start a
container or a virtual machine,
and so on.
So once you start
thinking about how can we
shrink the set of
stuff you actually
need-- only the
dependencies required
by a process or an application--
it starts really motivating
some interesting thought
patterns around how we're
going to design those
applications, what kinds
of applications are really
well suited for this,
and which ones
aren't, and so on.
So it really opens
up a new space
to think about how to
deliver and deploy,
and maybe even design,
our applications--
to take advantage of that.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So that's really interesting,
but from a practical point
of view, how do I,
like, run a unikernel?
How do I build a unikernel?
Is there tooling available?
Like, I'm obviously familiar
with sort or containers
that can sort of put
those in the cloud.
But do I need to run each
on an individual machine?
How does that work?
JOHN FEMINELLA: Sure.
Again, this is still in
very much an evolving space,
but there are many
different-- right now,
we're sort of in this
meritocracy phase, where
everyone's trying to do a
bunch of different projects,
and we're trying to
figure out, like,
what are the best approaches?
And that's still very
much an evolving idea.
So there have been
a couple of attempts
to consolidate these
ideas into one location
where people can play
around with them,
but there hasn't been much
consolidation that I've
seen in the way of projects.
So people are still kind
of independently exploring
many different ideas.
And to get a taste of
the many different ways
that we get started
with unikernels,
I would recommend
that folks check out
a website called unikernel.org.
And this is the work
of a couple of people,
including Amir Chaudhry, who was
formerly at Unikernel Systems
and is now with Docker.
And he's done a
great job of kind
of collecting these different
projects into a single place,
and giving you a
really broad exposure
to the many different
kinds of ways
that you could actually
build a unikernel.
I will say that,
broadly speaking,
there are two basic strategies.
You either start with an
application that exists,
or you're willing to start from
scratch to build some service,
or whatever.
If you're starting from
an application that
already exists, you probably
have a POSIX compatible
application.
And if that's true, then
you can use something
called Rumprun, which is a way
of taking your-- basically,
a rump kernel is a special
flavor of unikernel,
where basically you can
build the software stack
you need for your application
without having to build all
the individual pieces yourself.
So for example, if you don't
want all the overhead of an OS,
you still may need drivers
to actually run that OS.
So for example, your
web application probably
needs access to TCP/IP, protocol
stacks, and things like that.
So you still need these pieces
to run your application,
and a rump kernel lets
you assemble those pieces
in a way that's POSIX
compliant, but your application
will still probably work.
And so that's one
way of minimizing
what comes along for the
ride with your application.
So you wind up with
a very compact image
that then you can run
on top of raw hardware,
or a cloud hypervisor,
so KVM or Xen.
You would take this image and
you would run it on top of Xen,
let's say.
So that's one strategy.
The second strategy is
you are willing to sort
of start from scratch.
So maybe you're just
experimenting, for example.
And there are what I'm
going to call, broadly,
language specific unikernels.
So there are operating
system stacks
that require your
application to be written
in a very specific language.
So for example,
Mirage OS is what
I would say is the canonical
unikernel OS for OCaml,
at this point.
So Mirage OS has a
bunch of libraries.
You have your application.
You say, hey, I need a
networking stack, or whatever,
and the Mirage OS compiler
determines, you know,
what the set of
libraries you need
is, and then compiles
that into a machine
image that you can, then, run
just like you did with the rump
kernel.
You can run that machine
image on top of Xen.
Now, the extent to which
each project supports
this, or the levels
of documentation
and how easy it is to get
started, vary really wildly.
I consider myself a
relative OCaml novice,
but I really liked Mirage OS.
I liked getting
started with OCaml,
and I built a really
small web service
that talks to a few different--
it's just like a quote service
so you can talk to
Yahoo and get the stock
price of a particular
quote, and things like that.
But it was really
easy to build, and it
was very straightforward.
So I've been liking
Mirage OS the most.
That's not to say that the
others aren't also great.
But you know, I only
had so much time,
and I don't want to learn,
like, 37 languages to try
37 different flavors
of unikernel OS.
But that's the basic
idea, is you kind of
have some mechanism that
turns your application
into a compact machine
image, and then you
run that compact machine
image on a hypervisor
of some kind that sits on
top of your bare metal.
And then you're running your
unikernel at that point,
so then it can receive
requests from the internet,
or write to a
database, or whatever
else it's supposed to be doing.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So if I understand
that correctly,
does that mean that if I
am running, for instance,
a web server in, let's
say, Go-- because I
like Go-- I could
eventually-- rather than
building a binary that runs on
Linux-- I could build a Linux,
like a unikernel
that contains my app,
and all the libraries
that it needs,
like DNS and all
that stuff, that it's
going to need for web servers?
JOHN FEMINELLA: Mmm-hmm.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: But it
could not include things
like, I don't know, like USB-C
controller, or a floppy disk
controller, or stuff like that?
Is that correct?
JOHN FEMINELLA: Yes, right.
Now, normally the
container that,
like-- like, if you're
running on Alpine Linux,
it probably saves a lot
of space by omitting
a lot of those kinds
of firmware things
that you aren't going to
need for a web application.
So you're already
probably saving
some space there by using just
a small base image for something
like a Docker container.
But for your Go web application
example, what you'd save over
the Docker container
are all the parts--
you would literally be removing
everything from the kernel
that your application
doesn't actually depend on.
Like, when you use a base image
from someone else's Docker
layer, you're
basically saying, I'm
going to use that because
I know it's minimal,
but there's no guarantee from a
compiler or from something else
that there isn't stuff in
there that you don't need.
Right?
Like, you're still--
there's no tool that's
taking your application,
analyzing it in some way,
and then saying, OK, here's
what you actually depend on,
here's the system calls you're
making, or whatever, and then,
compiling that unikernel.
So you have a sort
of a-- I think
the goal is that,
effectively, you'd
have a stronger guarantee
about that thing that's
the output of the compilation
process being minimal
for some definition of minimal.
That is, it's smaller to run,
it's quicker to start up,
and so on.
So that's what I would say.
I think you're
essentially right.
But I think there's the key
difference in that a computer
program is making a
decision about what's
going into your
image, as opposed
to a human being saying, I
want this, and I want that,
and I want this other thing.
That's sort of, I would say,
the fundamental distinction.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So I could say
that it's basically
the difference between
having just a binary with all
the possible symbols of all the
libraries that you are actually
importing to actually stripping
the binary down to the objects
that you're actually using--
that your program is actually
using?
JOHN FEMINELLA: Right.
I would say it goes
one step farther, which
is that your Go
binary, when you deploy
that, you run that as a
process on an operating system.
The equivalent thing on a
unikernel is that you run that,
and it is the operating system.
The only thing it knows how
to do is run your web server.
It can't start up MySQL.
It can't connect to
[INAUDIBLE], or whatever.
The only thing it knows how
to do is run your process.
It's a single consolidated
machine image.
So it's like the kernel-- it
would be as though the Linux
kernel was explicitly
written to run your Go web
server and your Go
application, and nothing else.
So you're just
starting that thing,
and then you're making a million
copies of it or whatever.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: So it
could be like the Linux
that I could start, it could be
distribution that only contains
my binary, and my binary could
be run as, like, process ID 0,
or whatever.
JOHN FEMINELLA: Right.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: But like,
it could be the main process.
Huh, interesting.
JOHN FEMINELLA: Exactly.
It's kind of like, if you're
familiar with the privilege
levels in traditional
kernels, you
may have heard of things like
Ring 0, Ring 1, Ring 2, Ring 3.
So userland code in usually
executes as unprivileged.
It lives in the top ring.
And then, there are basically
context switches that
happen into privileged mode.
I mean, that's
how your kernel is
able to do things
with device drivers,
and write to protected
areas of memory, and so on.
With a unikernel
operating system,
your application slash
machine image is executing
everything in privileged mode.
Everything happens at Ring 0.
There's no contact switches.
There's no handing back
and forth to userland code,
because there is
no userland code.
Everything is inside
the kernel itself.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So does that mean that,
if I'm building myself
a unikernel app, I need to
understand how, like, the Linux
kernel works at a low
level, so that I can tell it
what drivers to put
in and pull out,
or how is that process managed?
JOHN FEMINELLA: Yeah.
I mean, that's part of where
the usability efforts, I think,
are coming in.
So first of all, it's
not necessarily the case
that you need, quote,
unquote, like "Linux kernel
understanding," because there's
so much modification happening
to these unikernel OS's
that some of them-- like,
if you looked at
what the kernel code
looks like, it would be
unrecognizable compared
to the Linux kernel code link.
There's probably
some basic ideas
that are going to be in
every modern operating
system, like memory
allocation and virtual memory,
or things like that.
So those ideas will probably
have familiar implementations.
But in terms of, like,
looking at the code,
and needing to understand
what some constant means,
or something like that,
no, you don't really
have to do any of
that to get started.
So like with Mirage
OS, for instance,
you-- I will say
their documentation
is very good-- but basically you
effectively just write an OCaml
application, and from your
application's perspective
nothing really looks different.
You can't tell that it's running
on a unikernel environment.
You know, the Mirage
OS compiler is
taking care of all the details
of how that application is
actually doing
things, because it's
sort of using its own stack,
its own kernel, its own OS,
its own kernel OS, and
services on top of that OS,
to make your application
work in this environment.
And that's great,
because it means
that all the stuff that your
application doesn't rely on
is not part of the
kernel to begin with,
so you, again, save the
extra heavyweight steps,
or extra heavyweight
bits, of the kernel
that you are not using.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So we're almost
running out of time,
but there is a topic that I
could not be happy leaving out,
which is what about people that
say that unikernels are not
fit for production?
JOHN FEMINELLA: Sure.
I mean, I think that that's
maybe a little premature, given
that it's still a relatively new
area of not only development,
but I think also
thought about philosophy
of how we're going to use this.
And I think we don't want to be
too quick to set aside a tool,
just because there may be some
valid objections to it to begin
with.
You know, I think that
probably containers were not
ready for production in 2013.
Or I should say, Docker wasn't
really ready for production
in 2013, and Solomon Hykes
and all the Docker people
vociferously said this multiple
times throughout 2013--
that it's not ready
for production,
but, you know, if you're brave
and you want to experiment
with it, you certainly can.
And I think that's
kind of the phase we're
in now with unikernels, where
this is really just starting
to catch the
attention of people.
And there are many
implementations.
They're all trying to
demonstrate that their version
is a good one.
And we're still
waiting for the dust
to settle a lot before we
start getting into these more
specific details of, like,
how does debugging work
in a unikernel environment?
How does tracing work?
What's the right way to do that?
How do you deploy these things?
Are the kinds of applications
that are suitable
for unikernels maybe different
than what we're imagining,
or what we think
might be suitable?
So there's a whole
range of, I think,
questions we can ask
about unikernels that
don't have answers right now,
or the community is working on,
trying to figure
out the answers for.
So it's definitely
still early days,
and I certainly wouldn't be,
like, running my Fortune 100
bank enterprise stuff on it.
But I think it's absolutely
worth taking a look at,
keeping an eye on, because
chances are good that, in 2018,
when you guys have me
on for the two year
anniversary of this
podcast, you can ask me,
where have unikernels been
on the last two years,
and I bet my answer will be
something like it probably took
the same path that
containers did,
where there was
gradual adoption.
We realized that there
is a specialized use
case for this
technology, and then
we exploited that specialized
use case to really get
the benefits of the technology.
Just like containers
aren't suitable
for all possible
applications, unikernels
won't be suitable for all
possible applications.
There will be some specific
set of things that's really
well suited for unikernels and
some things that aren't, and
that's OK.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
Very interesting.
And you actually mentioned
Amir Chaudhry from Docker,
and you also mentioned Docker.
So I got to meet him
during Craft Conf.
We'll have a link to
the slides of his talk--
were really interesting.
But I'd be curious to
know your opinion on why
do you think Amir is now
working for Docker, meaning
why did Docker buy that
unikernels company?
JOHN FEMINELLA: Yeah.
So first of all, I'll just say
that I've never actually met
Amir in person,
but we've chatted
a bunch over Google Hangout.
So thanks, Google.
But he is just clearly
doing amazing things,
and is a brilliant person.
And I think that, even if
the company had zero value,
it would probably be worth
it to hire Amir and his team,
because there's a
certain set of people
that, if you talk
to them, you just
realize that whatever
they're working on
is probably going to be amazing.
And so I don't want to set
Amir up for too much pressure,
but I'm sure that
whatever he's working on
is going to be great, and I
look forward to seeing it.
So I think, if
Docker hired them,
it's probably because they
saw what Amir and his team
are capable of, and
what they were building,
and they wanted a piece of that.
And I think it's
probably fair to say
that, if Docker bought a company
called Unikernel Systems,
and the word unikernel
is right in the name,
then they're certainly
exploring, and or actively
using, unikernels
in a way that's
probably ahead of the rest of
the industry at this point.
So I expect that, as we
start seeing industry
best practices come out
of the operation of things
like unikernels, I expect
to hear a lot about Docker
and what they're doing
with it, and kind of look
to them as a role model
for how we use unikernels.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
Well, I guess we
have to wait till the second
anniversary of this podcast
to interview you again and
see how much of that was true.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
go back in time.
So we are running out of
time a little bit, John,
but is there anything that you
would like to mention that you
haven't had a chance
to mention yet,
or a topic you want
to cover real quick?
JOHN FEMINELLA: Well, I would
say that, if folks-- or so,
as I said, one of the things
that I'm very interested in
is how businesses use platforms
in their deployment pipeline.
Like, where do they see
platforms coming into play?
And we've gradually been very
excited about containers.
Then, people realized, OK, well
the orchestration of containers
is a problem, so we have
things like Kubernetes,
and other technologies
to help us,
like, manage those containers.
But I still feel like
there's something
that we should be thinking
about, as an industry,
in the workflow with
respect to if you
had a developer-- a
container, or a unikernel,
or a virtual machine,
or something that's
not their application--
then they're still
responsible for a lot
of the stack, right?
Like, they have to
do a lot more things
before it's actually running.
And I want to see
us, as an industry,
move towards better
tooling around
how we manage containers,
and how we turn applications
into it's running somewhere
and I can, like, you know,
hit it with an HTTP request.
And that, I think,
is an area that we
need to pay more attention to,
and that we are sort of slowly
evolving.
Platforms are playing
a role in that,
but I know that we're going
to see awesome things come out
of Kubernetes, and
other technologies.
So I'm encouraging the
listeners of this podcast
to think about, when you
deploy an application,
is your next step, like,
put this in a container,
or do you want this to be, hey,
do something that puts this
in a container for me,
so then I don't have
to worry about the details.
Like, that, I think, is a
really interesting proposition,
when I can get back to
writing code, instead of,
like, operationally managing
37 containers and clustering
technologies, and whatnot.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Very good.
Very interesting.
I totally agree
with that, actually.
Well, thank you so much
for taking the time
to talk to us today.
JOHN FEMINELLA: Cool.
Yeah, thanks for having me.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: And
talk to you in two years.
JOHN FEMINELLA: Yeah, I'll
see you on May 12, 2018.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
We'll book it in now.
JOHN FEMINELLA: All right.
Thanks, guys.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks
so much, John,
for joining us on
the podcast today.
That was a really interesting
and enlightening talk
about unikernels, something
to keep an eye on for sure.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And we'll definitely
have the link to his talk
at Container Camp.
I think it was a very good talk.
So if you're curious about
more details on unikernels,
it's probably a good
resource to check out.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
But let's talk about the
question of the week.
Fransesc, you had a really
interesting question there.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, so the question
regarding your pet peeve,
your favorite project.
MARK MANDEL: My
favorite project?
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
Deployment Manager.
And it's basically about,
OK, so Deployment Manager,
basically what it
allows you to do
is, given a file that
contains some description,
you will create all the
resources on your Google Cloud
Platform project.
And that is cool.
But is there any way
you can create that file
from what you already have?
Meaning that, via either the
CLI or the web interface,
you created a bunch
of, I don't know,
instances, cloud storage
buckets, and whatever,
and you want to basically create
the corresponding Deployment
Manager, so then
you can replicate
that same infrastructure
somewhere else.
MARK MANDEL: So as
of about 15 days ago,
there is a beginning
of doing exactly that.
I would say it's definitely
not, like, 100% there,
but it's an open source project
that sits within the Google
Cloud Platform Deployment
Manager samples repository,
where there's a genconfig
Python script where you're
able to point it, I think
primarily right now, at GCE
instances, but hopefully
that will sort of grow
from there, as we get
issues and pool requests,
and be able to get back a
basic sort of Jinja template
that's able to be used
with Deployment Manager.
I think you'll have to
tweak it a little bit.
But it definitely does a lot
of that bulk work for you,
so that, if you want to
get started with Deployment
Manager, but you've already
got some infrastructure,
and you want basically be
able to either replicate that
somewhere else, or maybe modify
it using a Deployment Manager,
this is a really
great place to start.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
That sounds really
like a very good place
to get your files started.
And then from
there, you're going
to see all the things
that you're missing.
And there's two
things that you can
do-- one is add
them to the file,
the other one is send
the full request.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, absolutely.
Yeah, so I mean, this
is on GitHub right now,
links are in the show notes.
So if you start using it,
you find issues, definitely
submit it back.
We'd love to have input
from the community.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: And I'm
curious about one thing.
In what language is it written?
Oh, Python.
MARK MANDEL: It's Python.
So Python.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: '80s Python.
Oh, well.
I might still contribute to it.
Cool.
So before we finish, why
don't you did tell us, Mark,
what are you going to be doing
in the next couple weeks?
MARK MANDEL: So next
week, 3rd of June,
here in the SF
Google Office, there
is the gaming event we're
having here, Change the Game.
I'll be here for that.
I'll be doing possibly 1,
1 and 1/2 presentations.
So I'm co-presenting,
possibly a couple of times,
depending on how things pan out.
But that should be
a really fun event.
We're going to have Googlers
there to talk to people.
If your interested
in game dev, and you
want to hear from both
customers and Googlers,
and talk to, like, Google
and people about products,
absolutely come down.
I'm going to be around all
over the place after that.
I'll be visiting
GDG Twin Cities.
I'll be at Open Source North.
After that, I'll be at a
conference, dev.Objective().
And then I think
I'll be in New York
later in the month for
another gaming event.
I haven't got all the
details for that either.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Wow.
MARK MANDEL: So
bouncing around a bit.
How about yourself?
Where are you off to?
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Not much.
Just biking from San Francisco
to Los Angeles, like one does.
That's pretty much it.
After that, I'm relaxing
until July, where
I will speak at GopherCon.
MARK MANDEL: Very nice.
Very, very nice.
What are you speaking
on at GopherCon?
FRANSESC CAMPOY: I'm talking
about nothing, literally.
I'm going to be presenting--
the name of the talk
is Understanding Nil.
MARK MANDEL: So it's basically
this Seinfeld episode
of GopherCon?
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Exactly.
Yeah, and it's going to
be the opening keynote,
so I don't know how
that's going to go.
I think it's going to be fun.
I will have fun,
that's for sure.
MARK MANDEL: It
will be fantastic.
I expect big things.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: So before
we finish this episode,
there's one more topic
that you're actually not
ready to discuss, but I
would like to bring it up.
MARK MANDEL: Uh-oh.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Which
is that amazing match
that we had playing
Query It at Google I/O.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, yes.
Oh, yes.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I just wanted to make
everybody know that basically I
destroyed you.
MARK MANDEL: You won
by like a thin margin.
Like I thin margin.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Like a little bit.
Luck.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Yeah, luck.
Obviously, that's
what you will say.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
you'd been standing
in front of that for,
like, the whole day.
You knew all the questions.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
That might be true.
A little bit of an
advantage there.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
That's how we settle
battles here at Google.
We play Query It.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Yep.
Using the power of big
data to settle battles.
MARK MANDEL: Exactly.
So thank you so much
for joining me yet again
this week, Fransesc.
Always appreciate
you taking the time.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
Thank you, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: And thanks very
much to all our listeners
out there, too.
We really appreciate you coming
and listening to us speak.
We love having you listen
and provide comments,
and do all that sort
of good stuff, too.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And talk to you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: See you next week.